so chapter 27 we're looking at the slave
community so we're looking at the
American South and book talks about the
southern colony is that this being a
places where slavery slavery flourished
they were also been underdeveloped and
what that meant is that a lot of the
things that we've been looking at at the
chapter so far you know the
Presbyterians coming in and the
Congregationalists up in the in the New
England colonies or their Dutch Reformed
those churches were not really
interested in stuff the Presbyterians
have come down later on but we're not
present in sufficient numbers to really
do an awful lot
there were Baptists in a Cell but but
not a ton of them at this time as a
matter of fact a lot of the American
South would be what we would call on
church meaning that any sort of
religious life was up to the the person
and probably you know the closest church
or even organization might be miles and
miles away so many of the American
slaves the Africans that have been
brought over in their descendants we're
not getting any sort of formal training
in Christianity and many of the weights
in the South were either so there
weren't a lot of third year missionaries
like your book points out many whites
that know active life that really just
like themselves yeah there were some
other things that contributed to this as
well why you know once you actually have
missionaries and Bibles and religious
institutions why did the southern whites
be leery of letting black slaves have
too much content
are there any themes in the Bible that
might you know raise people's hopes and
aspirations think back to Judaism when
they're talking about yet
yeah and then Moses becomes a really key
figure in a lot of African spirituals
and Egypt would be who I think the the
Hebrews were slaves at that time right
so who would who the Egyptians be the
plantation owners so you know the Bible
is full of they're nice that and if you
let people read it this is sorta like
talking with the Protestant Reformation
if you let people read the Bible
directly they'll often find things in
there you don't want them to find and so
you know restricting access to that sort
of thing was one one way in which the
white slave holders could keep the black
slave population down your book talks in
about the 18th century and a number of
different developments that can work in
the opposite direction the opposite
direction of one of the opposite
direction of their not being an awful
lot of mission work done among African
Americans as the economy develops as
communications developed churches start
to spring up yeah southerners themselves
become you know in sort of demographic
terms more religious yeah along with
that goes African Americans becoming
more than just because they're the part
of that that economy some of the worries
that they have was well if you let these
people be baptized then they'll become
part of the religious community and then
how are Christians supposed to treat
each other are they supposed to enslave
each other generally no so there were
worries that if you allowed baptism then
you know baptize slaves it starts you
know saying we're equals and that would
really go not only against cultural
mores but it would the economy of the
south was intrinsically dependent on
slavery so you know your book talks
about colonial legislatures making sure
that that wasn't actually going to be
the case there was some mission work not
an awful lot
move it towards whites and then towards
blacks your book also points out
Catholics in Louisiana and Maryland
including sable and Jesuits were more
conscientious than mostly providing some
religious instruction but for the most
part they're kind of left on their own
that book talks about the Great
Awakening and we've we've focused on
this quite a bit why is the Great
Awakening important well it raises
certain denominations what are some of
the denominations that you remember
being really small before the Great
Awakening and then start sort of taking
off any comes in mind yeah yeah I mean
it started off because two little
churches in Rhode Island yeah by the end
of the 18th century there's quite a few
of them by the end of the 19th century
there were one of the dominant forces in
American Protestantism he and some of
that growth takes place in the south so
remember we talked about Baptist
churches being very portable they're
easy to move from place to place to
spring up Baptists and Methodists are
coming out of the Great Awakening and
they're doing some mission work in in
the South now we got to be a bit careful
in thinking about the history involved
here because it's not as if the Baptist
churches they came down south and
immediately started initializing
african-american slaves instead
sometimes there would there be you know
looking at the Baptist model and doing
things along those lines without
actually be in any sustained contact
with them and then later on when you
asked you know well what denomination
are you would be easier to say Baptist
the Methodist and then other things as
well so your book talks about something
they all
we're a religion business taking place
so they say the more authentic
indigenous Christianity that emerged
among the slave communities between the
Great Awakening and the civil wars
frequently described as the invisible
institution why because it's invisible
from the outside and it doesn't have any
sort of legal status these are these are
people who are being sort of you know
police the very bottom of the social
hierarchy so what went on with that
there's very little organization but
there's a lot of firmament there's a lot
of sort of new ideas new approaches
coming in and so your book talks about
the religious lies that plantation
blacks haven't kind of split quality are
you gets familiar with this term
compartmentalization for any of these
associations sociology majors or
psychology majors if you comfort
mentalize your life what do you think
that means like you're a student right
now right do all of you think of
yourself as students all the time what
are other roles that you yeah that's
then you think of that that are really
matter to you it's a student managed to
I think hopefully you're not studying
constantly what else are you guys are
athletes that's a wall sometimes you
can't give all at the same time what
else what are other key roles that are
very different than being a student yeah
whoa family relationships the
son/daughter hopefully nobody's in here
is you have a mother and father but
somebody's online brother-sister that
sort of thing
that's very different than being a
student yeah you might have certain
expectations of yourself
as a son or daughter that are radically
different from that of being a student
for example under the purple law your
mom and dad can't senior grades back in
the day they could and you sort of
straddle two different worlds there's
you go home on vacation
and now I don't they still treat you
somewhat like a kid so whatever your
parents you're still a little little boy
or girl and you say I'm 20 I'm 21 22 you
got to knock this off I'm old enough to
do XYZ there's the attention there right
and that's what we call
compartmentalization when you start
splitting here your life into these
different things you might end up doing
that later on with work and with family
having two very different ways of
looking at the world so that happens
with plantation blacks why because
there's this desire of white to utilize
Christian teachings like they say
especially certain texts of Paul that
say slaves should obey their masters to
reinforce a spirit of obedience at the
same time in private this this invisible
institution or communities of religion
let's say for worship they're carrying
this out as well and this is part of
their their life experience this is part
of their culture so what's going on
there's a number of different aspects to
this that your points out and it talks
about this this mode of Christianity do
something being something like a full
religion that combines elements from the
European
and African heritage so what are some of
these these characteristics one is
preachers as senators of the community
features were based on charisma rather
than education and why well because it
was illegal to actually educate African
Americans to teach in to teach a slave
how to read or write was a punishable
offense even in some of the northern
states but but definitely in the South
in large part so that they wouldn't be
able to read and use the Bible to say
hey Bibles kind of against this or hey
what about that Moses guy and this story
over here
charisma means having sort of this
personal connection being able to be a
good speaker and that's what made
somebody in a preacher you didn't have
to be ordained you didn't have to be
able to necessarily even read your book
also talks about folk or formulaic
preaching you could think of this as
having something like a repertoire of
stock phrases and ways of thinking about
things that you could then build into
something like a sermon how many of you
are how many began to do public speaking
in your classes okay how many of you
like doing public speaking just those of
you who like doing public speaking did
you always like doing that or did you
have to learn how to get comfortable
with what made you be comfortable
corrected okay so what practice consists
in actually getting up and then doing it
when I first started teaching I was kind
of nervous about getting in front of
class my first classes I suppose I
must've been a bit nervous or anxious it
helps if you actually have some
structured did they ever teach you to
use like no cards and it's like that
now imagine them no cards in your head
and you're carrying around the same
stock of basic note cards all the time
because you're probably not just giving
a speech for class you're going to be
giving these same sort of speeches your
entire life it's bit similar to what
many of you are going to do on the job
in the workplaces that you're going out
into in the disciplines that you're
studying
there are certainly basic ideas that you
can keep using over and over and over
again you don't want to have those
written down you want to actually have
those available to you in your mental
file cap yeah it works that way to be
preaching to preaching in this respect
is very similar to what poetry used to
be like poets before things started
being written down I don't know if you
guys know this from you know your
history of literature for instance Homer
how many of you read The Iliad or the
Odyssey yeah probably like the end who's
required reading in high school or
something like that you may not have
enjoyed it that much but here's one
bringing that up before that stuff was
written down it was passed down orally
and these bars would have that same
mental file cabinet up in their head
stock phrases that they would use over
and over and over again and for instance
in the Odyssey and in the Iliad what is
that word you have allowed to escape
from from the gates of your mouth that's
a stock phrase that gets that pops up
over and over and over again why do they
keep saying the same repetitive stuff
because that's easy to remember and you
can fit it into the genre the the
narrative in this case the the narrative
is going to be something about salvation
something about Christian life so this
reliance on on stock ideas and phrases
is very important another thing that
they talk about is the call
response Adam this is where the preacher
would be saying something we should have
over a response directly after that from
the audience call response call response
there's a back and forth kind of rhythm
with this it's very participatory we
don't do this as much in education
nearly imagine that I was to come in and
there was gonna be more like a
motivational speaker you know how do you
do it today and then you all say okay
well then I say no how are you really
doing it today all right great
then we go back and forth like that
that's what Paul response is like and it
produces a kind of feeling of being
involved that's why that's why we use it
as a technique or other similar things
like that in a lot of different settings
not so much in the academic lecture
because we also talked about
incorporation the ants and movement they
talk in particular about the arena shout
the highly the rhythmic clock tower
clock wise shuffled answer which the
whole body participates in the movement
and where is this coming from
nobody really knows there's congestions
that is coming from traditional African
religion and culture in any case it
finds its way into pre Civil War
southern slave religion period within
the invisible institution like we're
talking about and one of the other
elements that they touch on is song and
here we're speaking specifically about
the genre that's called the spiritual
so what would be examples of spirituals
your book gives you a number of
different go down Moses roll Jordan roll
were you there when they crucified my
Lord and even goes so far as to talk a
little bit about music theory doesn't I
don't know if that made too much sense
to you when they talk about the
pentatonic scale didn't you know that
what that means I mean there are going
to be musicians here you no longer you
have a lot on your place pentatonic
scale is the scale that blues is
actually based in but you know blues is
coming about later on these spirituals
are are around first and they're useful
like you know were you there when they
crucified my Lord goes know that so it's
not using the entire scale it's using
just some of these it's using five of
the notes and it's a very powerful way
of organizing music a lot of these
spirituals would use biblical themes and
they would have actually not even really
coded messages there they're pretty
overt they would be about liberation it
would be about how to stand suffering
they would be about the faithfulness of
God to the Israelites and the
african-americans identified with the
Israelites or with the Hebrews as the
oppressed people so all of these
elements come together in African
American religion in the South your book
also talks about a debate that takes
place between these these two different
explanations about how much of this is
actually coming from coming directly
from African roots and you know the long
before answer to this is nobody really
knows in part because when you're
dealing with things that have passed
down orally it's rather difficult to you
know say definitively that this this was
or wasn't the case so
where it ends isn't talking about uses
this term tertium quid are you guys
familiar with this means third something
and what happens with with
african-american pre-war slave religion
is that we've got European Christianity
and you've got some African roots in
culture that's not completely stamped
out which also isn't able to attain
expression of the sort of things that as
well as didn't say Santeria or condone
play or vote on in other places and they
merge together to form something this
third of the African American religion a
new synthesis like the book talks about
invoking elements from each tradition
but blending them with unique concerns
and experiences of the African American
slave community now what are we looking
at this here in this chapter is it just
enough to be representatives we don't
want to leave African Americans out or
something like that it's not data this
is actually going to influence in the
South in particular American expressions
of Christianity and not just within the
African American community but also in
the wider community more through through
culture than through religion think
about for example spirituals and the
role those play in American musical
history there happens to be quite
important so you wanna those sort of
things we're going to end the story here
yet with this chapter but we're gonna
retake this story up after the Civil War
talking about what happens with religion
itself and then enters what happens with
with African Americans as they leave the
south and and head out you know through
the great migrations into the northern
cities